[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it is the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships talking about the real
thing I am your host Jade warshaw I am
joined by maybe my favorite co-host ever
Dr John deloney over here to my right
we're going to have a good time give us
a call the number is 8825 5225 we'll
talk about your life we'll talk about
your money we'll talk about your mental
health and wellness but before we get
into that Dr John we were just in the
NYC we are in New York City this morning
Party in the USA we were partying in the
USA we were in New York um for a media
dinner we got to sit and hang out with a
whole bunch of cool folks yesterday and
then we did some media this morning and
then we got on a plane and flew here
just in time to save him America I'm
like pinching myself somebody has to
good grief I'm like what is happening I
I went on social media yesterday and I
was like all right you know come check
out the TV we'll be on Fox news with you
know America's Newsroom I was like wow
that's crazy then this morning I was
like hey come check out the TV we'll be
on here with Fox and Friends I was like
wow that's crazy our life is just really
been cool and it's all thanks to you
guys uh thanks for listening to the show
thanks for sharing the show thanks for
tuning in whenever we talk we couldn't
do it without you guys and without
further Ado we got to take it to the
phone lines we got Jessica in NYC we
just came from there Jessica what's
going
on yeah hi well thanks for visiting us
it was fun um I bet um so I am my
husband and I are trying to start to
prepare for my retirement um in
approximately five years um I am a
teacher locally and I will be retiring
with a large pension approximately
$100,000 a year um but I also have an
opportunity to get a lump thum
um which is quite significant how do you
determine what is the best course of
action whether to take the pension and I
know Dave usually says to take a lump
sum but due to me being so young and
potentially um being able to collect for
an extended period of time and get
spousal benefits for my husband yeah I
just want to know is there a calculator
or a formula that you use to um to pick
yeah you know I all I can tell you is
what I would do and I'll tell you the
reason why I would do it and then if you
have some information that kind of
contradicts that feel free to share it
um the reason I would take the lump sum
and in my case you being a little bit
younger is actually a good thing cuz I
would take the lump sum and then I would
get with a smart Vestor Pro and I'd
reinvest it and you are going to get a
better rate reinvesting it in good
growth stock mutual funds across the
four types that we teach you're going to
get a better rate of return than you
were ever getting with your pension um
because even the way we teach it we say
like hey we we suggest for people to
invest 15% of their income right but if
somebody calls in here and says hey uh
I've got a pension and I'm putting you
know 10% into it does that count as 10%
we tell them no count it for like 5% and
we say that because of the rate the rate
of return that you're likely getting on
that pension and so in your case if I
were you you're going to walk away with
so much more money because if you get
with the right investor and in the right
funds you're going to have an awesome
rate of return I mean what are you
50 uh I will be 50 this year so I have
um about five more school years after
this one oh yeah that's great and I mean
you're going to retire but I'm sure
you're going to go on to do other things
it's not like I'm going to work I'm a
worker I'm so there's no no doubt that
I'm not going to work but I am concerned
because my husband is not going to have
a pension or a retirement we do have a
four 3B but I am concerned to make sure
that I'm preparing for him and leaving
the Legacy for my kids 100% if you take
the lump sum how much is
it um it's estimated at
1.33 million good girl I would do it
right now let me let me tell you two
other things let me tell you two other
things
um the first one is you are never
guaranteed
tomorrow right and I wouldn't have a job
if everybody lived to to be 95 years old
right and before this I spent a lot of
time in homes in the middle of the night
hugging husbands because their wives
have passed away from and I have had
health issu issues I'm a cancer survivor
from 36 so if you imagine your kids and
your husband you've got this incredible
pension that makes you're getting paid
six figures and then you get sick and
then some happens and then they're out
and he's 60 years old with nothing
versus you got this so I it almost feels
safer to me to know I've got a million
dollars in the bank that is going to
compound every seven years if invested
properly it's going to double and so
you're thinking man if I live 21 more
years right just to the average
um it'd be a little below average then
you would have three four4 million right
four and a half I mean so you see what
I'm saying minus whatever yall withdrew
so I'd pull it out here's the second
thing I would tell you and I'm just
telling you this like if I was sitting
across the table from my
mom I personally I don't have any secret
info but I don't see a path forward for
all these pensions to pay out as they've
promised similar to Social Security
they've been so heavily leveraged and
borrowed against and bonded out I don't
trust the fact in 30 years they're going
to be paying what they are I just I just
I don't see a path forward especially
with their grown-ups in Congress acting
like children throwing crayons at each
other I just don't see it John you make
a good point and that's a good thing to
remember Jessica is a a pension can die
with you like and you mentioned wanting
to take care of your family so that's
one thing or if your company goes under
that also puts your pension down the
tubes if New York had we were just there
and everyone we talked to talked about
how New York hasn't come back yet the
real estate um you know all those
shuttered first floors of all those
buildings that used to be just hopping
if it would not surprise me if New York
has to um sit down with the union and
negotiate and it' be a bloody battle and
you know it would be but I just don't I
don't see a path forward 30 years from
now now hopefully I'm wrong I would do
anything to be wrong um but man I'd much
rather have $1.1 million in my checking
account that's under my control that I
get to decide what happens to down the
road than to Hope New York makes good
choices
because they have don't have a great
track record so Jessica you're going to
take that money get with that smart
investor Pro you're going to invest it
across four types we teach this all the
time 25% into each category you got
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international that's what you
want to do that is the path forward do
you have any
questions well what if we wanted to take
some of that money and purchase some
real
uh I would ask since I'm going to hos
anyway I would ask if you are in baby
step seven and if you are I would say
yes do that becomes part of your your
portfolio at that time you will be yes
that's the way to do it we're gonna
relocate and get off of Long Island
which is ridiculous yes ma'am that's the
way to do it when you're in baby step 7
you pay cash for real estate and you
become even wealthier than you already
are which is pretty dang incredible I
love calls like that John it's awesome
very cool and thank you for being a
teacher and
I'm looking at the statistics um jade
and Jessica thank you for not just
quitting this year I know that's right
you're going ride out for five more
years thank you those kids in New York
are lucky to have you and you're
modeling for them what a hard worker
looks like and a thinker looks like I'm
so grateful that's awesome in more ways
than one I love how she's wanting to
take care of her family I love when
people really dial into um their money
not just for the now but for the future
because the the choices we make can cost
us hundreds of thousands of dollars when
it comes to investing what we're looking
at what we're not looking at so I always
admire when people are smart enough and
diligent enough uh and intentional
enough to call in and really get the
right advice for their money hey and by
the way this is just an in equals one
experiment but my parents both changed
careers in their 50s and they are
incredible into their 70s so your
husband says he's not going to have
anything he could if he chose right now
to start doing something different it's
not too late this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by the their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
[Applause]
[Music]
what's going on everybody you're
listening to the ramsy show thank you
for listening I'm your host Jade warshaw
joined by John deloney give us a call
we'd be happy to take your call we'll
discuss whatever you want to as long as
it has something to do with your money
or your mental health John over here is
really the best best guy to talk about
mental health and wellness tell them
what you do John I'm not the best guy
there's some really good ones out there
but we'll talk to you about your
relationships mental health whatever's
going on in your world your emotional
health life has gotten sideways for
everybody and it's a mess it's a mess I
like the way you talk about things
though because for me there's no like
lingo like it's not over my head it's
like oh I can do that like that's me
he's talking to me so that's one of the
things I like about the way you speak to
the People John including me I'm one of
those people but give us a call 825 5225
and we'll chop it up we got Ashley in
Columbus Ohio what's going on
Ashley Hi how are you both doing good
how are
you I'm good I'm a little nervous so I
wrote down my question that's awesome um
just a slight just a slight background
I've had three surgeries in a year and a
half so the fact that John delone is on
here talking about mental health these
surgeries have definitely weighed on me
mentally um because of that we slid back
into baby step two due to all of the
medical bills um that we accured with
that
um we were making really great Headway
until earlier this month we received a
letter in the mail stating that we had a
$2,000 bill that was about to go into
collections um we had never received
notice of this bill prior um so when we
inquired more about it um it was from
2021 to two years ago for physical
therapy from my first surgery um we got
negotiated down from the 2,000 to about
1,300 okay um however we're having a
problem with the office giving us a
final bill and writing that that is our
going to be our final notice and I don't
want to be on the hook for $600 when I
can't get anything in writing and
honestly I just want these medical bills
gone for for my mental my mental health
and wellbeing have you driven over
there um I have um and I've talked to a
supervisor and they said we'll give you
date that you know that it went over it
came down to a dispute from my prior
insurance and my prior employer um but
not willing to give me anything in
writing other than the date and the most
recent Bill we got was 1,800 so it came
down a little bit but I'm afraid again
we're going to be on the hook for all of
that if we can't get something in
writing do you have
it I have a voicemail from them do you
have
$1,800 um not really we've got our
thousand emergency fund and slightly
over that we have about 12 and so we're
working pretty quickly to get all of
that you said the bill was col you said
the bill was in collections right no it
was the final notice prior to
collections okay got it got it um let me
tell you what I would do and Jade tell
me if I'm
wrong I'll do just about anything for
peace in my home and I would probably um
as your husband as your neighbor as your
somebody that went to church with you as
as your as your sister I would go Drive
Uber I would go babysit I'd go wash cars
I'd go do something and scr scr up this
money and just pay the stupid Bill and
be done move on I it's so and that's
what my husband and I talked about as
well I it's just not worth my soul now
my friend George Campell would he would
he would get a tent and Via very bougie
nice tent because that's how he rolles
but he would go park it in front of the
hospital and he would or in front of the
PT place and he would sit there every
day until they finally so that's how he
rolles everybody's different I
personally if they did the if they
actually did the therapy and they did
the work that they're claiming that they
did I would pay them the money and be
done with it I try to figure out a way
to make iten and here's the other thing
you know this as well as I do one of the
things that surgery the mental health
toll surgery takes is there's that
scary sense that my body let me
down right there's something about me
that's not working right and then
there's that pervasive pain that hurts
all the time
and they work you through therapy to
slowly take teeny tiny little baby steps
with that pain one of the ways you
regain trust in yourself is not through
standing in front of the standing in
front of the mirror and manifesting it's
a whole bunch of little winds and my
promise is if you and your husband scr
and scratch and Claw and get 1,800 bucks
and just get this stupid thing paid over
paid out even though it's going to cost
you some time you're going to miss some
te- ball games you're going to miss
whatever you will stand a little bit
taller mhm that's a path right you'll
have little step little step little step
boom y'all are done you're out of our
life and then you'll say all right we
did it and then that will catapult you
into getting back to Baby Steps three
and four and
on okay yeah and that's that's kind of
what our second um kind of our fallback
like hey if we have no choice but to pay
the 1800 and we don't take the discount
then that's kind of the end of the the
story with that and we move on to the
next medical bill um and I agree with
what you said it you know I do feel like
my body has failed me since it's it's my
series that's that's how literally it's
exactly how I feel yeah and one of the
best ways to get confidence back in your
body is to slowly begin to use it again
right both intellectually both working
really hard towards a towards a purpose
purposeful goal and doing physical
things right and it's just one of those
things that it you you feel like I'm
going to do this workout and tomorrow
I'm going to feel like a million bucks
and you don't you look in the mirror and
you kind of look the same it's little
bitty things that accumulate over time
and then suddenly something's going to
happen and you're going to be strong and
you're going to think oh wow I'm back
right it's awesome it just takes a bunch
of little steps over and over and over
and it's disciplined and it's annoying
and it's slow and it just happens and it
happens and you're all going to get
there and get it done I agree with that
wholeheartedly I'd pay it um I want you
to keep every piece of paperwork on this
I want you to keep this paper trail
especially if it's been inconsistent the
thing that's probably consistent is the
account number so they'll be a if
there's ever a discrepancy you'll be
able to see hey this account went from
2,000 to 18800 I paid it you know you'll
always be able to see that so always
keep the paperwork um especially if you
are dealing with a collections uh
company you definitely want to keep the
paperwork because those Jokers will come
back you know five six seven years later
talking about you didn't pay because you
made a settlement so always keep the
paperwork always in a file folder and do
not give them your checking account
number they're going to ask you for the
routing number so they can just um
direct withdraw it do not oh that's such
a good point don't don't don't send a
money order or have your bank wire it
but do not do not do not do not do not
give them your in information because
you'll have money leaking out of your
account for the rest of your life
absolutely yeah in this case definitely
case all right let's go to Manuel oh no
let's go to Nia she's in Orlando Florida
what's going on
Nia hi how you doing doing good how are
you good um so I just had a question uh
me and my husband just recently decided
uh to do the baby steps um we uh
um our income just recently dropped
because he lost his job uh from like
880,000 to
50,000 um and we're already kind of like
living paycheck to
paycheck uh before that um so I wanted
to know if we should catch up on pass du
Bills first before uh saving an
emergency fund um or do we do the
emergency fund catch up on pass the
bills and then go into paying the debt
okay
yeah so I want I do want you to do the
baby steps in the order I do want you to
get cuz here's the thing that $1000 if
you don't have that money you're going
to just go you're you're just going to
go more and more into debt and these
things are going to get more and more
past due but the key to making this work
because I don't want you to rob Peter to
pay paal the key to making this work is
you've got to get that income back up um
he lost his job what's he doing in the
meantime um I have
uh he's been kind of working my business
um I have a
bakery uh so are you paying him
we no money that we get so it started
off as a hobby like literally since we
needed extra money like I literally pop
the 10 out in my front yard in the house
and we just sell like cupcakes and stuff
to the neighborhood and whoever walks
past that's great for you Nia but right
now right now he's got to get a job that
pays I want him
applying to like eight jobs today and
this is not the the be all end all this
is whatever's local this Home Depot this
Amazon this is whatever he can get very
quickly and start making money very very
quickly I'm going to give you a couple
of numbers so you see how quickly this
needs to happen the average person gets
their $1,000 saved in 30 days that means
you're selling stuff that means you are
working day and night that means if
cupcakes are making you a little bit of
money but you can make more money doing
instacart this week in this month you're
doing instacart stop stop making KES
yeah right now we're doing whatever is
going to make us the most money because
not only do you need to get this
thousand saved you got to get caught up
on your bills and if it's rent we're
getting caught up on that one first if
it's IRS we're doing that one second
then we're working the debt snowball
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast preapproval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com to today to learn
[Music]
more thank you for listening you're
listening to the Ramsay show I'm Jade
warshaw your co-host host with together
with Dr John
deloney we're taking your calls all
afternoon longle 8825 5225 we're going
to do it up with the neighborly question
of the day today's question of the day
is brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly is your one
place to find Reliable HVAC plumbing and
electrical providers near you Brands
like airserve Mr Rudder Mr Electric have
local professional ready to help so stop
wasting time scrolling through pages of
results when you can just visit
neighborly decom today all right today's
question comes from Josh in Oregon Josh
writes I have no debt except for the
house and I have one credit card I've
never paid a penny of credit card
interest I treat it like a debit card
and pay it off every 2 to three days
next year my husband and I will acrew
$122,000 in medical bills due to having
a baby and my husband's medical
condition meeting our insanely High max
out of pocket my brother recently showed
me a few credit cards that have a $1,000
bonus if you spend $44,000 in the first
three months since we have medical bills
and the cash to pay the bills he
suggested we get the credit card and use
it to pay our bills get the credit card
bonuses and immediately pay it off with
cash I know you're very against credit
cards but what is your opinion on this
go you called the wrong
show
um yeah dude you called the wrong show
and I think that you should go with your
first instinct because you said
basically what does it say John she said
that she knows that we don't do credit
cards right I think she said that on
there except except hold on she's
special she's special and there's a
medical condition a baby and oh so she's
the exception to the rule correct oh
well in that case I'm still going to
have the same advice that we always have
no credit cards I would never ever ever
and this is being real I would never
ever ever suggest anybody to use a
credit card really ever the only time is
if for some reason they had like a maybe
if they were upside down on a car right
and their credit was shot and so they
couldn't go to a credit union you know
to get a little extra money to get out
of that upside down situation then maybe
I'd say okay do it on a credit card
right because you're going from a large
amount of debt to a much much smaller
amount of debt that is the only time you
would probably ever hear me say the
words here's how you could use a credit
card but in this situation you have
money you have money and $1,000 doar to
shuffle around debt in order to get
$1,000 in in in the time it took me to
answer this call you could find a more
productive way to make $1,000 I'm just
saying all right so here's my
two here's my two challenges with this I
actually get the math on it yeah the
math is fine you you'll make your money
cool assuming everything goes according
goes perfectly right so I know the
stress of having a baby another the
stress of having medical conditions I
don't know why anyone would elect to add
additional stress to that situation I
know to add more chaos like okay we got
to remember to pay this one off because
this one's got a th000 we're going to
roll this one over to the 4,000 and then
we're going to spend this in the three
months we got to make sure we get this
bill back I don't know why anyone would
do that that's number one okay but
that's not enough for the math the math
folks I get that too it's everything is
worth it if you get that $1,000 or
whatever here's my beef these credit
card companies are not your
friend and so you are the rare and when
I say rare you're an albino unicorn okay
you don't exist in their world because
if people like you existed in Mass they
would close they'd go bankrupt they
wouldn't exist you pay it off every two
to three days
cool so that $1,000 bonus you're going
to get is going to be paid for with late
charges by that single mom who cannot
breathe in Southern Arizona whose
husband just left her and she can't see
the light of day somebody's paying that
thousand bucks and it sure as crap ain't
the credit card company and if it's not
you it's people that they've been
praying on that they are desperate
that's why I quit using them when it
came to Airline points I traveled all
over the place it makes perfect sense
for me I'll just get reimbursed and I'll
get all these free miles and it occurred
to me wait a minute those flights aren't
free I love flying Southwest but they
are not my friend they're a great
service that I give money to so
somebody's paying for those flights and
we dug into it it's people who are in
deep terrifying financial trouble and
those are the folks that call the show
every day those are the folks that email
us and DM us every day and they're
literally dying inside that's a that's
I'm not going to let a single mom who
can't breathe pay for me to have $1,000
in bonus cash or a free flight to Dallas
I refuse to be a part of that game I
love that I I actually really like that
way of thinking about it um and I think
that probably if you were to take a poll
of all the various Ramsay folks here
we'd all have a different reasoning for
the credit cards and I love that reason
that's definitely something to chew on
um my reasoning is slightly different
but similar but different my reasoning
behind it I mean we can get into math
stuff and you know debt and all of that
but mine is and and you can tell me what
you think about this John I don't like a
company who a a mass majority of their
profit and revenue is based on people
defaulting failing failing the customer
has to fail customer has to fail for
them to make money of course they get
money on transactional fees and all
these other things but the money that
they acrew in late fees and overbalance
I'm like wait a second cuz I can go
there's plenty of companies out there I
can go to Jordan brand and buy a pair of
shoes and I don't have to fail in any
way in order to get the service that's
right like I can go over to Publix use
their you know grocery store service or
Instagram and or instacart you know
grocery shopping app I don't have to
fail in any way to get value from their
service anytime a business's main profit
source is the failure of their customer
think Blockbuster they didn't make money
on renting movies they made money on
your late fees you had to lose you have
to lose for them to win they will go
away yeah if you provide a service like
an incredible shoe that has value that
looks cool we're just here serve you we
want to give you fashion I'll give you
my money you give me fashion right
that's a fair TR transaction but if they
fall apart or if when the new Jordans
came out if they suddenly pushed a
button like maybe one uh fruit company
that makes cell phones does and they
pushed the secret button and your phone
starts working not as well right yes the
big red button they only make money when
their customers fail yeah I have a major
problem with that and then okay let's
keep let's keep rolling this out cuz we
got time on this clock John so there's
that part let me tell you my next part
about credit cards they get into your
psyche and they have told us for decades
you can't exist without us and so Brick
by Brick they've torn down our
confidence to be able to handle money as
individuals because they've said hey
your paycheck's not enough you working
hard 40 hours a week is not enough you
need supplement you need extra you need
more you need to be able to keep up and
here's how you can do that we'll give
you this piece of plastic we'll loan you
our money insane interest rates and now
there you go now you're good go play and
so now we talk to folks all the time who
call in and they're like Jade I'm
terrified I'm terrified to cut up my
credit card it has nothing to do with um
I want to get the points and the rewards
and this no I'm just scared that I won't
be able to manage my money without this
safety net that I've had in my life for
5 10 15 years that's crazy and I hate
that a company has had the ability to
destroy our confidence in that way to
just go oh yeah yeah if I mean if I make
$3,000 a month I just I can only spend
$3,000 a month like I can go into I have
the confidence to say I go into the
grocery store and I just only spend $200
I have the ability to tell myself no and
I have the ability to say oh if I say
this is the goal and this is the plan
yeah I'm confident that I can stick to
that but we've totally wiped that out of
our Consciousness and out of our
confidence and now we're like oh I don't
think I can say no like I don't think
that I can actually stick to this I
better keep that piece of plastic as my
fail safe so that's that's argument
number three you got another one I got I
got a number four let's go so they're
going to give you a $1,000 bonus if you
spend 4,000 in the first three months
cool what they are banking on is that
you're going to spend $4,000 in the
first three months they're going to give
you 1,000 bucks they'll get that money
back oh yeah they will get that money
back and here's how the research shows
you spend more money when you're swiping
plastic than when you're paying with
cash or even coming out of your debit
card and so you might pay this thing off
every 2 to 3 days but your expenses are
higher percentage wise than if you were
just carrying cash around that's right
because it doesn't doesn't matter you're
going to pay it off later so they're
going to get their $1,000 back in
transaction fees that you otherwise
wouldn't be spending they're going to
get their money back opt out of the game
don't play with Predators man do not
play the game we're not playing with you
guys when it comes to these credit cards
we are only going to tell you what we
know to be true this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software Ware systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsey we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we use to optimize and take
us to the next level netweek gave us the
visibility into all of our numbers so
that we could communicate across
departments and plan ahead better and as
we grew it scaled with us
netw week worked for ramsy and it will
make a difference for your business too
join the more than 34,000 customers who
trust netsuite to help make them smarter
and make better decisions and level up
their operations to learn more get a
free product tour at netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
[Music]
you are listening to the Ramsey Show I
am Jade warshaw this is John deloney
we're with you all afternoon give us a
call 8825 5225 we just came from New
York City uh where we do something
really cool there John um you know we
get the opportunity to go on different
people's television shows news networks
podcasts and there's a lot of people
that go into making that happen so many
folks behind the scene producers and
Bookers and all these people and I think
Ramsey does something really cool by
hosting a dinner to just say thank you
to just appreciate all the people that
let us let us near them and let us on
their Airwaves and trust us and it was
really cool to see that um how much goes
into that and so in the spirit of that I
really just want to say thank you to
those listening now thank you guys so
much for listening to the podcasts the
YouTube channels everything I mean the
fact of the matter is John and I would
be unemployed if it were not for you and
so we're just super duper grateful um I
don't think we say it enough thank you
and let's um let's let's show show
people a little bit behind the curtain
um he would never do this on the air but
Dave's a Gruff guy on the air and he's
tells it like it is you know it's when
you see Dave um in the the the lower
basement of a building and the way he
interacts with and tips the Bell hops in
the shadows that nobody will ever see
yeah and the way he said 10 years ago
man we're going to all these people's
shows and there's the the hosts in front
of the cameras mhm but there's all these
people behind the scenes making this
thing happen and their life is they're
up at 3 :30 in the morning they're
making up all the all the shows making
sure everything's running and gun doing
far more work than us way more work far
more work than us Dave said we've been
blasted beyond measure I'm going to fly
my whole team up to New York and we're
going to take care of them for a night
and so it's just that there's a
generosity that's staggering behind
closed doors um this is pretty cool to
be a part of it is very cool but just
want to take that moment and kind of let
you know what's going on let us know
that we thank you guys for listening if
you enjoy the show it means so much to
us that you even have the grace and just
to share it that you click subscribe all
of that it means so so much to us not
only does it help us but it helps
somebody else uh they get the message
out they get the word they get that that
that message that's going to change
their money that's going to change their
mind that's going to change their family
it's so so so important thank you and
with that we're going to go to manwell
in Houston Tas what's going on hello
guys thank you for having me you're
welcome thanks for calling in what's
going on
uh so I'm actually in a big mess uh so I
have a backstory I'm a starter so you
guys understand okay uh about a year ago
I went through a really bad pH of
depression and well I made some dumb
mistakes that I'm now paying
for um I got myself into $70,000 of uh
de I purchased things I I knew I
couldn't afford but I just didn't care
at the moment and
well today I'm making uh roughly about
$20,000 a year maybe a little less than
that I am working on getting my uh CDO
my commercial driver's license so I can
make more money uh it's just this is
really hard to get right now but to
break it down for you I have about 19 or
18,000 in credit cards and uh personal
loans debt okay I have uh bought a car
uh it's a very expensive car you guys
are going to be so angry on me how much
it was $50,000 I now own 46,000 on it
and I also bought a motorcycle that I
owe like 5,000 on it you owe 5,000 on
the
motorcycle yeah okay um which do you
want to get first do you want to get
John's take or do you want to get Jade's
take you get to choose but you're gonna
get both uh either
one all right here's the deal man first
thing before you get going I need you
when this call is over to go look in the
mirror and look yourself dead in the eye
okay I need you to say the following I
screwed up but I'm not a screw
up the game changes right
now okay yeah I need you to repeat that
over and over and over I'm worth fixing
all this stuff okay the funny thing you
calling me and Jade 70,000 bucks doesn't
make either of us blink because we've
both had way way way more debt than that
okay and both of us have gone through
ups and downs so same team all right um
the $50,000 car that you owe 46 Grand on
that's sold by the end of next week
right yeah and after TR selling the car
already uh I just owe so much money on
it and uh they will only give me like
34,000
so have any money to uh pay for the
upside down when you looked on if you
look on kellybluebook.com what's the car
worth or have you done that yet I've
done it yeah uh
$35,000 so it's worth 35 you owe 46 so
10K upside down yeah yeah 9k all right
um we're going to deal with that we're
still getting out of this car cuz at
this point
40,000 is worth it to take a $10,000 hit
so we're going to talk about that why oh
real quick why are you only making
$20,000
man um well uh I don't know how to do
msh um that's not true don't I don't
believe that for one
second not for one second yeah that's
not
true yeah can you deliver pizzas yes can
you drive Uber yes can you go find a
construction site of all those building
sites out in Houston and just throw
brick yes hey yes you don't want to work
you're going to work tomorrow right and
you think that what you know how to do
is not important and it is important
because that's what's going to keep food
on your table that's what's going to pay
off your debt it is so
important yeah I agree are you let's
let's change that hey are you in manuell
yeah I'm in okay we we believe in you
and we can't believe in you more than
you believe in you okay
yes sir yeah okay uh we're locking that
in so $20,000 I know you're working to
get your D your you know to so you can
drive trucks CDL but in the meantime
there's almost anything that you can do
is going to make you more than $20,000
McDonald's if you're working 40 plus
hours a week and I want you working I
mean are you a single guy do you have
kids uh well I have a girlfriend that
don't
count that doesn't count Felicia and
look in this season we're eating at home
in this season it's McDonald's at home
and it's Bob cuz you don't have any
money okay and let her understand like
hey right now I've got to focus on
getting my life together I don't have
the money to do to I I like you a lot
but I don't have the money to just be
taking you out to whining and dining you
not that you're doing that much anyway
on 20,000 but I certainly don't want you
using a credit card to do that so the
game changes today we're going to get
another job any job I want you doubling
your income in the next month or two all
right and you can do that we're doing
that that's a yes all right yeah next
thing is I want you out of this car
how's your credit I'm guessing it's in
the toilet yeah it's terrible I
completely my credit when I took all
these loans and I'm actually miss
payments already I just can't afford to
make those uh to make some payments
anymore my credit Cars and personal
loans yeah I need you so are you current
on the car or you're behind I'm current
on my car uh just because I need the car
I live in a big seat I need to move
around can you go sell that motorcycle
this weekend for 5,000 bucks 100% I'm
also upside down on the motorcycle I
don't care how much how
far uh they only give me like 3,000 I
owe 5,000 so I'm like two grand outside
if I were you I would try to get I would
try to find the difference um if you
can't get a loan or a personal loan I
try again this is the one time I'd
suggest a credit card see if you can
find you know a 10 or $15,000 balance so
you can get out of this car give them
the 10,000 clear the Gap then take 5,000
to get you a cash car you're buying a
car in cash do your research get the
best car that you can get and you're
going to be $40,000 Less in debt sound
good yeah I I mean I've tried that
already I used to work at a dealership
for like two years and I know how the I
know how that works it's just that I I
there's no way nobody will give me a
loan for there uh I've tried selling it
I've tried getting a loan for so I can
get another car and drive it around but
you know I'm just too deep in the hole I
guess all right then the next the next
play is I want you to look deeper into
that but the next play here is you've
got to get your income up because at the
end of the day here's what here's what
we know is true you can pay debt off as
long as you stop creating debt you can
dig yourself out of the hole when my
husband and I started out with debt man
well I want you to hear this we made
30,000 combined we had
$460,000 of debt when I tell you things
are possible it's possible
but it demands you getting stupid on
this debt it demands you working so hard
to get your income up and I'm not
talking about overnight this is year
over-year month over month gains you're
growing you're getting better you're
earning more money you're decreasing
what you spend and over time your life
is going to change you're seeing the
value and what you put out into the
world and that's what I need you to get
out of this call you can do it when it
comes to your money you can tell me that
you won't do it but don't tell me that
you can't this is the Ramsey
Show hey what's up guys it's Jade if you
love the show and want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I am Jade warshaw joined
by John deloney we're taking your calls
all afternoon your life your money your
mental health give us a call the number
is
8825 5225 we're happy you're here we're
happy that you trust us with your
situations thank you for doing that and
uh let's go straight to the phone lines
we got Carlos in Los Angeles California
what's going on
Carlos hi can you guys hear me we can oh
perfect hi well actually I can't believe
I'm on this I just I discovered you guys
uh like last week last Thursday YouTube
and the podcast yeah so what do you
think so far welc to our crazy gang yeah
man and I literally fall asleep like
last week and let me give you a
backstory so I've been listening to you
guys nonstops since last week you know
I'm I'm 31 the H say is 29 and on
Saturday we had a a t about finances
because I was listening to you guys hey
Carlos talk hey hey Carlos talk directly
into your phone for me uhuh oh okay
sorry I apologize um so we talk about
site about like having a budget
angry at the I can't hear you brother
are you are you on speaker phone hold on
Carlos Carlos can't hear you man
Carlos
Carlos Carlos can't hear you brother we
can't hear you hey we might have to come
back to you in a minute because we
really couldn't hear you next time uh
we'll get the call back but get off
speaker phone or wherever you were
getting better service and then we'll be
able to help you out until we get Carlos
back let's go to Brian in Philadelphia
what's up
Brian hey how are you
good what's
up um so I just had a quick question I
don't really have any sort of um issue
with saving money but my question is
about uh student loan debt uhuh um I got
lucky with it and I got half of my
college paid for and I went to a cheap
School sweet um so I only have about
12,500 um I have more than enough saved
up where I could just pay that off and
not have you know not have that debt
right but um I have not been making
payments on it due to the pause and
thinking that maybe um it'll be it'll be
canceled or at least $10,000 so my
question is is it worth just tackling
and knocking out or is it a better idea
to just continue making payments and
Brian it does it make you feel warm do
you love
it do I love what the loan
I do not love the loan no like when
nobody's around do you go in like your
room and shut the door just hug it do
you love
itan the dream of the dream of
forgiveness died several months back pay
it off right now what are you doing pay
it off and
and um I'm going to say something and it
might
sting okay um pay off your student loan
and and do it with knowing inside your
heart man this is awesome that I have
the money toay pay this
off because so many folks call our show
and they don't have the money to pay it
off not today and not for a couple for
several years on down the line and when
you wait out for forgiveness people who
didn't even take out student loans or
have their own they're fitting the bill
and so when you have the money to pay
pay so that other people who didn't even
have student loans aren't going to have
to pay through any type of who knows
what will come down the pipe you know
next election year or whatever maybe
somebody's going to talk about
forgiveness again but always remember
nothing's free like first rule economics
there's no such thing as a free lunch
right everything costs and it costs the
taxpayer and if you're a person in this
country that can pay the bills that they
signed up to pay pay it you called the
wrong two people cuz both Jade and I
paid off hundreds of thousands of
dollars and I'll tell you right now
Brian if if those if those forgivenesses
went through and Miss Jade had had to
add that to her taxes I'd be fired up
cuz I already paid
280,000 you know what I'm saying Brian
yeah the part about the timeline and and
I definitely got your answer uh on that
and I kind of had a suspicion that you
might say that yeah um but I was
actually to pay it off and then right
when I was about to pay it off the whole
thing came up that it might just be
forgiven so I figured if I paid it and
then it immediately would have been
forgiven I would have thought to myself
I should have invested that money
elsewhere but you know I totally get
your point though I think there's a
bigger thing there's and I think we lose
this this I think we lose this um
globally there is a a psychological and
in turn a physiological response to
Integrity to standing up and keeping
your word telling the truth there's a
reason why truth telling is woven into
the fabric of every Faith tradition in
human history there you you walk
differently and when I was 18 and I
signed up for all the stupid loans I
signed up for I had no idea what I was
signing up for Jade NE I mean none of us
did we were just doing the next thing
everybody told us but we both put our
names on a piece of paper and said if
you help me get through school I'll pay
you back you did too and so I can see
that you would have been like dude I got
$10,000 more dollars in my pocket you
know we got bailed out by the government
Jade's right number one anytime any time
a government agency bails you out they
will come knocking for a piece of Flesh
at some point if you've ever sat in a
history class they will come back to
your door and say where's mine so always
count on that but the big thing is is
you would you would be like oh man I
should have invested it but I did what
was right because I put my name on a
piece of paper and I said I'd pay you
back and there you go here's my money
and I'm I'm moving on to the next and
you know what thanks for that call Brian
because we needed to talk about this
with with the people don't you think
that everyone would like to open up
their bills and go ah I'm not going to
pay that
that I mean no one wants to pay their
bills no one wants to give away money
like it doesn't feel good and it doesn't
it's not fun especially when you didn't
realize what you're doing yeah
absolutely but I'm saying it's it's not
fun to write your check for your car pay
or you know pay online I'm sorry I just
aged myself no one wants to send that
online pay payment for their car but
they signed up to have a car payment no
one wants to send you know even though
this is a little bit better you know
your insurance payment you know and
you're like God I never even use this
thing and it's not fun to give away your
money but when you sign up for something
you say that you're going to pay for it
and there is that piece of it that's
there and when it comes to these student
loans yeah I I can really get into this
here's the thing and I want to validate
this because I felt that John I'm sure
you have too with student loans is very
different because you're looking around
you're going yeah I was 18 somebody
should have stepped in like it would
have been nice if some adult had gone
hey Jade you don't need to take out that
much student loans because you know
you've got a full ride scholarship you
don't need to take out student loans to
get your hair done and go to parties and
buy groceries like that's dumb Jay don't
do that I would have loved if an adult
did that I would have loved if an adult
stood and really explained compound
interest to me when it's working against
you I would have loved that but nobody
did I would have loved so many things to
be different about that situation for
the people to say hey don't put your
loan on forbearance because when you do
that it's going to accumulate interest
in you faster than you've ever could
imagine no one did that and I can spend
my whole life blaming them or I can go
oh let me change my whole life I can't
blame my way to a better life I've got
to change the situation pay off your
debt that's all it is man this is the
ramsy
[Music]
[Applause]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can say save
thousands of dollars to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumps some payoff option you could
qualify for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y refi.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
thank you for listening to the ramsy
show I am Jade warshaw joined by
best-selling author Dr John deloney and
I'm actually really excited John because
you have a brand new book coming out
it's coming out Tuesday just a few days
days it's a few days that's right hey
I'm excited tell the folks about it
building a non-anxious life in a society
and a generation we have everything
we're anxious beyond measure anxious
beyond words and so wrote a book called
building an non- anxious life and it's
um it's exciting to say it's breaking
all the internal pre-sale records and um
it's got just a couple more days when it
gets to Monday at midnight the um all
the pre-sale goodies will be gone and I
think it's 75 bucks they say of uh of
free stuff that that comes with it get
online Ramsey Solutions .c or John
dooney.com and pick it up and then come
Tuesday October 2nd October 3rd yeah
third October 3rd it will be in all the
stores all across America and everywhere
else but I'm excited man let's get it
out let's get it out let's get it out
that's exciting so can I just ask
something of course what store when this
book comes out what store are you like I
want to go see my book sitting on the
shelf in this store I was an old like
man I used to live my wife I used to
live in bookstores and so going like
seeing a book in Barnes & Noble's pretty
Rad or walking by SE it in a target's
pretty cool I mean it's just just see
it's just surreal none of that surre
it's just weird I'm excited for you that
is super duper cool make sure to get
your copy I know I got mine ramseys
solutions.com that's where you want to
get it let's go to John and Washington
and by the way if you want to take a
call if you want us to take your call
give us a call 88255 225 and we will do
just that without further Ado we got
John in Washington DC what's going on
John hey guys uh thank you for taking my
call absolutely how can we
help um so I I I had a quick question so
um so my wife and I um um recently
actually just paid off my student loan
and we're completely de free now except
for our mortgage way to go yeah that's a
slow clap right there good job yes and
we we've been uh listening to Ramsey's
um show for a long time so um you guys
help turn my mindset around to do this
the right way love that um so on that
note like we're we were thinking about
so we we currently own a condo in this
area and um we have a baby and we're
going to be putting her into day care in
about a month or two and it's kind of
expensive um in the area so um but we've
also been looking at houses because we
really want to own a home but we are not
sure if that is smart idea um uh we make
decent amount of money but we're we're
not sure we can really afford it and
with the interest rates going up and
prices just keep Rising we just feel
like we're never going to be able to
attain a home and uh we're not sure
we're just looking for some advice on
what you guys think we should do yeah
and how we should plan for the next
steps to hopefully own a home in the
future yeah absolutely I think you're
asking all the right questions and I
think you've got the right uh set of
Weights in place it's like okay we got a
baby we got daycare coming up yes we'd
love to have a home all great questions
to ask um my first question to you
because if we do do the math and figure
out yeah you guys are ready that's great
but I want to make sure that you've got
a couple of things in place do you guys
have an emergency fund fully funded
three to six months of
expenses yes yes we have um um we have
savings um but I mean I just spent about
like $40,000 to pay off my student loans
okay so what do you have
left so we have about um i' would say
about
50,000 um in a savings account okay
probably another 160 stocks um and we
probably have around
another um I would say 80 in retirement
accounts okay so you've got 110 that's
non-retirement
right yeah okay so that's great um I
would knock that down or siphon it off
in your brain to whatever three to six
months of your expenses are so are you a
person who you feel would need three
months to feel comfortable of emergency
expenses if one of you were to lose your
job or six
months I would say six months but six
months okay so if just quickly in your
head basic expenses I'm not talking
about a full and by the way for anyone
listening when we talk about an
emergency fund it's not your full budget
times six it's what you really need to
just keep your home running all right if
everything gets down to the wire right
only what you need to survive that
doesn't include the restaurant budget
and nails and you know if your wife gets
her lashes done that doesn't include all
of that it's this is your basic what it
take barebones budget three to six
months what would that be for you for
six
months probably like 20K I think oh only
20K okay are you
sure well so like our mortgage right now
is about like 2500 M um and probably
other monthly expenses if we really had
to cut back probably could go to like
500 to a th a month oh wow y'all are
living y'all are Living Lean um okay put
30 in there for fun thank you I was
gonna say just for me can you keep it at
30 put 30 in there for fun let's go with
30 I'll feel better about that um okay
so 30 set aside that gives you 80,000
coming up uh to start putting towards a
down payment okay so now what we want to
think about here is how to buy a house
to where it's a blessing for you and
it's not a burden all right which is
you're going to have to do your research
and I really want you to run the numbers
we've got on Ramsey solutions.com we've
got a mortgage calculator you can check
out or you can just Google um how much
home can I afford Ramsey Solutions
calculator pop up right there but at the
end of the day here's what I want you to
aim for John I want you on a 15-year
fixed rate mortgage write this down
15year fixed rate mortgage I don't want
the payment to be any more than 25% of
your take-home pay now this is your
take-home pay after taxes only all
right see that's the problem right now
because I feel like that that payment
that I would calculate so like I've been
listening to you guys and I know the
whole 15 year old 15 year Rule and all
that right now we have a 30 year old a
30- year old 30-year mortgage and our
monthly with principal interest taxes
and everything PMI is 2500 right and
even that feels hard for us and that's I
mean I'm going to I'm going to be honest
with you yeah your payment your payment
for what you get is going to be higher
because you're cutting it in half you're
saying I'm not going to pay for a home
for 30 years I'm going to pay for home
in 15 years and if you do it our way
it's going to be even less do you know
let me tell you something John the folks
who walk through our steps they become
debt free they pay off their house in
the next 7 to 10
years cuz the goal here the goal of
everything we teach this is not just for
you for anyone listening the goal here
is Ultimate peace and the way you get to
Ultimate peace is there's no payments so
we want you to pay off your home if you
get a 30-year mortgage at that point
what you're saying is I'd rather have
more space I'd rather have a bigger home
I'd rather have all of these things
rather than having the piece of owning
my home not to mention when you don't
have a home payment do you know how
freaking rich you're going to be because
how much you're going to be investing
every month
John talk to him about it well John what
what are you do in Washington Washington
DC uh so I'm an engineer and my wife uh
works for a a company as a um she's a
legal professional okay so this is a
conversation that millions and millions
and millions of Americans are having
right now which is
this we really wanted this particular
job in this particular field in this
particular
City it could be because we want to be
New York people we love the energy of DC
we love the the legal profession here we
love the ex the wife
great what we're telling you is the math
doesn't work in your favor and the
question you and your wife have to ask
and it needs to be like in an
intentional fun where let's go get
breakfast together and get some a sitter
for the kids or for the
kid it's a dreaming conversation but
it's a hard conversation which is what
do we want more do we want to have
access to concerts 4 minutes away and do
we want to live by the subway do we like
the quote unquote energy of the city or
we want a
home because the world needs legal
professionals you're an engineer you can
get a job all across America and you can
cut your living expenses by
2/3 right and you can get a house for
for in some places for half you know
you're 50% there um with just your down
payment depending on what city and state
you move to so the harder question is
what are we willing to give up for this
dream of owning a home what we're
telling you is mathematically speaking I
don't care about how you feel about it
cuz I know you want one we all do you
cannot afford it given what you make
where you live you'll have to deal with
that
[Music]
reality
hey folks Dr John deloney here with some
great news you get to choose whatever
you do good or bad moving forward the
choice is yours and when you're
intentional about making good choices
over time they become Healthy Habits
Like choosing to slow down and make time
for a daily practice of prayer and
meditation one thing that has helped me
with a daily practice of meditation and
prayer is hallow hallow is the number
one Prayer app in the world world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's 3 months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling Hall
makes it easy to practice mindfulness
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and choose peace remember poo is
giving you 90 days free imagine the
peaceful habits you can establish in 90
days go to hall.com Ramsey today and
follow the simple prompts to start your
free 90-day trial that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey
[Applause]
you're listening to the ramsy show this
is Jade warshaw this is John deloney
we're taking your calls all afternoon
John what's coming around the pipe all
right we got two big things going on
October 5th this is next Thursday I'm
throwing a book release bash we're gonna
have punk rock music and singer
songwriters and a PO it's gonna be D
It's Gonna Get Off the rails they gave
me 1 hour to plan whatever I wanted and
it's going to be a blast um we're going
to have a we're going to have a about an
hour program and then I'm going to sign
books and um take pictures until every
single person is ready to go so um
that's October 5th let's up um go to
Ramy solutions.com for that and our
first ever money and marriage getaway
October 19th through 21st in Nashville
me and Rachel Cruz we're going to equip
you and your spouse with tools to cast a
vision for your family set goals create
a life that you both love we're going to
be talking about money we're going to be
talking about sex we're going to be
talking about everything that couples
are struggling with right now and we're
going to have a ton of opportunities for
you
to get oneon-one or two-on-one direct
coaching in conversations it's not going
to be us lecturing this is going to be
more conversational more um think think
graduate school not um huge lecture hall
right they're going to be interactive
sessions and me and Rachel Cruz are
going to be your guid to discuss
communication boundary sex money all of
it tickets are 799 bucks it's a whole
weekend it's going to include a great
fun event um one one of the nights it's
just going to get off the rails also if
you're out of debt you got room in the
budget please come see us Ramsey
solutions.com
events and we have couples who have been
married a few months and we have couples
who've been married 20 30 years who are
circling back and say okay we want the
back half of our marriage to be more
awesome than our first first half and so
we've got people from all over the
Spectrum hope you'll join us ramsy
solutions.com
events like that let's go to Detroit we
got Kylie what's going on
Kylie hi there thanks for taking my call
you bet what's going on okay so my
husband and I are in a situation um so
right now we are just not making end
meet meet we're in the negative every
month and I'm trying to figure out if we
F bankrupt or if we I don't we don't see
another way so we're just trying to
figure that out right now so the bills
that you have we're not paying the bills
that we have and I'm assuming there's
debt as well right so we have that we
can so we we're paying our bills we
we're not behind on like food house
electricity any we're we're doing the
taking care of ourselves and you're
paying minimums on the debt as well yes
okay yep so can you kind of list out the
debt for us yes so we have um 880,000 in
student debt okay which we're we we're
not paying on and I'm in school so it's
all deferred um not that do exist but
are you still a crewing hold on are you
still a crewing student loan debt um I
think technically it opens up this
weekend right no I mean you said you're
still in school so I'm saying are you
still continuing to take to I am getting
yep girl we GNA talk about that we're
we'll talk about that let's take it one
thing at a time though so so far we've
got the 80,000 in student loans what
else yes um and we have 30,000 in
personal loan there's 25 personal loan
and then um another 5,000 is credit
cards okay and so you're in school are
you working at all while you're in
school I I work um part-time from home
we have four kids and we homeschool oh
wow part-time from home four kids you're
homeschooling what are you earning
working part-time from home um I bring
home around 21,000 a year okay and what
is your husband earning um he is making
right now he just got a new job in his
new degree field um and he's only making
36,000 a year what is he
doing he's doing software support so he
went and like got his it and coding
stuff and he couldn't find a better
job yet when I hear what the coders are
pulling in in this building it makes me
wish I'd gone to coding school that's
what we
also thought but I mean we would take
any leads
okay here's when you tell me your income
my brain goes to the average income the
median income in America and I I'm
always striving to get people at least
to the median all right which is around
67,000 just to know like all right I'm
in the game so I really want that to be
your goal very very quickly um you got
$115,000 in debt um if we want to make
this needle move the secret sauce here
is getting the income up and running
like
cranking and
the thing that I the thing that I want
you to understand is you're you can't
solve a problem while simultaneously
creating it and right now you're still
adding to the debt and so any movement
that you make forward is going to feel
futile so what I want to do is stop the
bleeding and so you're going you're
going to school now what's the endgame
of this um so I'm in my masters to be a
licensed
counselor okay how much time is left and
how much more money is being added to
this bill
um how much time is left like three to
four years I'm doing very part-time and
I I honestly don't even know the end
like probably at least another 50 can I
say something really hard don't do
that can I say it John I'm I'm I dude I
I've got a PhD in counseling I'm gonna
tell you don't do it I was a I was a
graduate school Professor here's why I'm
telling you that 50,000 on top of the
other 80 for a clinical mental health
counseling degree
is going to be a nightmare to pay off
and dude I was a graduate school
Professor I need more counselors out
there I want people to go to graduate
school and get their counseling degrees
here's the deal you're broke y'all can't
afford this and you got four kids yeah
you have to make some radical hard hard
choices
like we want the idea of homeschooling
all four of our kids maybe they got to
go to public school for a couple years
where we clean up the mess that the
adults in the house made my husband
really wants to be a coder but can make
about that much money being assistant
manager at McDonald's right now he's
going to go find a job and a second one
too y'all are in a situation and I think
you want to have I want to be a licensed
therapist dude I want that so bad for
you we want to homeschool our kids I so
badly want that for you I want him to be
a coder because they keep saying we're
going to make $200,000 I want that for
him too but the reality is those things
aren't real right now what is real is
y'all can't breathe because um you owe
so much money and let me tell you this
and you probably learned this in your
grad school classes already your
children absorb the tension in your home
and if Mom and Dad can't pay bills the
mom and dad are struggling with each
other and those kids are absorbing that
every second of every
day see what I'm saying and so sometimes
it's a Dream Deferred several times in
my second doctoral program I had to quit
I took off a semester because I had to
take care of things at home I had to
take care of things with me and my wife
and so it may be the time and there's
going to be a state school that I
promise you can get a great clinical
master's degree that's going to be
infinitely cheaper than what you're
doing and you'll be able to pay cash as
you go I know it's hard but I you and
your husband aren't being yall aren't
dealing with reality and and I don't
mean that like you're not living on the
moon yall just don't make enough money
and you want to do this and you want to
do this you want to do this um if you
put all four of your kids in public
school on Monday and you went to work
full-time you instantly are able to
breathe
instantly and if he says three of them
are too young for school but yes okay
but you know you get you get the sense
of what I'm saying right um and or you
reach out to somebody at local church
and you get some help or you take your
part-time job and and your you look at
your husband say you're making 36 Grand
you were trying to get off the ground
with this great and I know you want to
be around with all four kids great but
we have to have more money right now
yeah there is going to be a sacrifice
there's going to be a trade no way
there's not a sacrifice there's going to
be a sacrifice there's going to be a
trade and that's based on what you say
the priority is I mean we can say this
is a money show and this you know John's
going to speak to the other side of it
but we're all always going to
prioritize what gets you feeling peace
and feeling freedom first and I think a
lot of times people think oh like
probably in your mind you're like oh
I'll get my degree I'll be able to earn
more money and that was the path but
then you pull back and you're like wait
a second this is just creating more like
frustration more debt more chaos and
when that happens you do have to stop
and regroup and go okay what was the
priority again what was the thing
because it can't everything can't be A1
if everything's A1 then you start going
crazy really quickly yeah and so
something something goes on the chopping
block and that's the really really hard
part of this conversation uh not just
for you Kylie but for so many folks
listening thank you for the call because
I think just by you sharing your story
it provides Clarity for a lot of people
cuz John you're so right you have to
make hard choices very rarely in life do
you get to just get all of it at once
well and you mentioned something goes on
the chopping block and if you don't want
it to be your degree it doesn't want you
don't want to be your career dream it
will be your marriage it will be your
relationship with your kids it will be
your peace something has to pay the
piper and so let it be the adults in the
house that is such a good word uh yeah
you got to make the sacrifice and you
know what sometimes I don't like the
word sacrifice John I like to call it a
trade cuz it's really what are you
trading what are you getting in return
and when you say it like that it has I
don't know a better ring to it this is
the ramsy
[Applause]
[Music]
show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
you are listening to the ramsy show I am
your host Jade warshaw joined by
bestselling author Dr John deloney host
of the Dr John deloney show love to say
that and uh I wanted to let you new
folks listening know that if you're
listening number one we're happy that
you're here but number two you probably
hear us talk about things all the time
that you're like hey I'm new here and I
feel like you guys are using some inside
jargon some lingo that I don't
understand help me understand and if
that's you I want you to go to ramseys
solutions.com and I want you to click
that little get started button because
that's where we're going to meet you
where you're at we're going to explain
this whole thing to you we're going to
talk to you about the baby steps we're
going to explain what all that means and
finally you're going to feel like you've
come into the fold the ramsy fold and
you're going to go oh my gosh I get it
now I loved the show before but I love
it even more now that I understand all
the things that they're talking about so
do that today go to ramsy solutions.com
click the get started button and uh
we'll help you figure out your best Next
Step here with Ramsey Solutions that's
amazing in the meantime let's go to
Michael he's in Scottdale Arizona
Michael what's going on buddy hey I had
a quick question for you guys I was
wondering at what point do you sell um
stocks and mutual funds to pay off baby
step number two uh I made a oopsie last
year and we're probably about 65% over
an individual stock purchase um negative
on that but at what point do we just cut
our loss sell it pay off baby step two
and just move on yeah you doing
man what what were you doing did you did
you get like an Insider tip did you like
read a magazine no absolutely not it was
an IPO opening and I was like oh this is
going to do well and it did not but oh
man you put all you pushed all your
chips in on that bet how hey I love the
way you said it was like it's just an
oopsie so it was either like 100 Grand
or it was 4,000 bucks what was the
oopsie it was 10,000 bucks I made an
investment and it's you know down to
about 4,000 now so um and how much is
the
debt um I've got about 60,000 uh in debt
right now um shoot yeah okay so I'm the
way you framed it was as though if you
sold the 4,000 in stocks or whatever
what it was in stocks that that would be
enough to clean up the debt is there
more money because you also said mutual
funds yeah I've got mutual funds just
some Savings in general probably um with
all that combined of maybe 35 40,000
okay and that's non-retirement
non-retirement accounts so we're close
to just paying off the debt and with our
income we probably can clear it in the
next you know six to eight months or so
so I'm just trying to it's hard to let
go of a loss like that so maybe the
market will go up but that's the whole
game right it never does or when you
need it well in this case I mean over
time it's going to go up and if this was
sitting in a retirement account I'd be
like yeah it's fine let it let it ride
but in this case you're trying to pay
off your debt and so I would definitely
say go ahead and liquidate that money
there's going to be a tax implication on
it for sure but in this case it's it's
worth it to you to clear this debt
you're still going to have about 15
16,000 left that you need to pay and I
it sounds like you'll be able to cash
flow that and get the rest of that out
of your life pretty
quickly yeah it it is yeah how much you
said you and your partner H can do it in
eight six to eight months how much do
you'all
make uh we make we own our own business
we make upwards of uh about 220 a year
wait a second good God Almighty how do
you not have this paid off by
Christmas you know what I know because
Michael's playing Michael you're over
here playing games aren't you Michael
you're playing games you're like I'mma
do a little of this I'mma do a little of
that it's so hard sometimes to you know
I don't know just not hang on to it
right and just kind of finally you know
I just finally kicked in um you know a
few months ago of like gosh let's get
this out of here why is it sitting here
why do we have this debt let's build you
know this freedom and wealth and you
know so I'm just trying to I I I would
love to see you cash everything out and
pay the stuff off this weekend and have
a huge celebration like do it right I'm
for real and then you and your partner
look at each other and you'll have um
October November and December and say
for Christmas our Christmas present is
let's owe nobody anything let's have an
entirely free household m we're free we
are free hey what's left to go on the
mortgage uh quite a lot we purchased a
home in uh the peak of
2022 and um but we we did gain a ton of
of equity in our previous home and so
you know we just kind of transfer that
over but we do we've got $675,000 okay
you make 225,000 so you're going to put
that on a seven-year plan you'll be done
in five yeah that and and thank you John
for getting to that because that's the
picture that I want to paint for you
going forward because I think you're a
smart guy I think you're a guy I mean
you've got a great income you've kind of
been dibbling and dabbling here and I
kind of want to give you the framework
for how you can do that in a way that's
going to give you peace and make the
most sense I mean hopefully you're
investing 15% of your income into
retirement is are you doing that or more
yeah we are I've got automation of our
you know our business just pays into our
into our plans and I'm trying to
automate that I've already put in a
thousand more towards principle of the
home just to do it you know just to say
it's starting to go in that and let's be
very intentional about that I mean over
here we would say invest 15% for
retirement and if you had kids put some
in the 529 and then you know be
intentional it doesn't have to be
everything that's extra going to the
house it doesn't have to be super
intense but be super intentional you
know like you said make it automated
every month this is the plan sit down
with your wife we're putting x amount of
dollars towards the mortgage and before
you know it that mortgage is going to be
gone and you're going to have the extra
money to play around with investing more
and if you want to do single stocks it's
like look I I've always talked to Dave
about that I'm like Dave when's the best
time to do single stocks he's like look
if you want to play around with stuff
like that as long as it's no more than
5% of your total net worth like whatever
knock yourself out but I think it's good
you have enough money to burn in the
middle of the living room right yeah I
mean
exactly time he's going to have money to
burn he's going to have he's going to be
a he's going to have his home paid off
at 600 it's wor 675 now right so it's
going to be skyrocketed by then so does
that does that sound like more fun
Michael it certainly certainly does yes
good I appreciate the encouragement and
the extra push will you call us back at
Christmas on on December 24th we have it
we have a like a show right before it
just to do your debt free
scream I'm challenging you I'm giving
you a 90-day challenge oo I appreciate
that I will um I'll talk to my wife and
we'll we'll work hard to get that then I
would love that that's like Yoda stuff
there is no try 90
days come on Michael you make a quarter
million
dollars yeah do it do look thank you
Michael for the call and hey keep
listening because this next thing I'm
going to talk about is kind of about you
and not just you Michael but so many
people let me tell you the most
dangerous place to be in John is when it
it's it comes in a couple of ways in his
case he's got a nice income and his debt
is there but it's not bling his world
it's not making him duck and Run for
Cover right or somebody who makes maybe
$120,000 a year and they've got 20
$25,000 of debt it's not like they're
not shooketh right they're just like
I've got this debt it's a little
annoying but I'll make it work King
James shook shth they're not shth when
you got Sam and Jade type debt to ratio
income you are under the ground you're
running for your life you don't have a
choice and so I those are those calls
are always the hardest because it's like
m I can bat It Around the Net a little
bit longer for now for now and those are
the ones that you look up and five years
down the line 10 years down the line
suddenly it starts eating a hole bigger
and bigger because you can't out earn
bad spending habits you can for a little
while but after a while it catches up
with you and it's going to bite it's
going to take a big old chunk out of
your booty can I say that online you can
and you said probably whatever we want
on L but also I always again I always
feel like I'm Debbie Downer it just
takes one shift in the market one thing
that that Scottdale decides to do with a
regulatory issue and your business is
over yeah and you have a $600,000
mortgage that was a great deal cuz you
rolled $300,000 in equity into it I
don't care yeah and now you've got
60,000 bucks and you can't eat look
right it happen we would not have a show
if it didn't happen that's not going to
happen to me I'm an engineer I'm a AI is
coming for you I've got I'm a this it's
coming for you right so be very very I
love you say cancer is cancer whether
it's a lot of cancer or a little cancer
you got to deal with it you got to deal
with it because that thing will grow and
at the end of the day really what it's
about is the habits that you're forming
you know when you say ah I know I can't
afford that I put on the credit card
I'll be able to pay it off right those
are habits that you're forming every day
and so what we're teaching it's so that
you ingrain better habits so that over
time you're building a better Financial
Foundation it doesn't have to just be
this one F swoop thing we want the daily
choices that you make ah daily choices
see what I did there
we want that to be what shapes your
financial future so that's how it works
Michael thanks for the call you helped
us you helped a lot of other folks
thanks for listening that does it for
this hour we'll catch you next
[Music]
hour hey it's Dr John deloney if you
love the show and want a deeper dive on
your money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the ramsy way just go to go to ramsy
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it is the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth we
help them do work they love and create
actual not fake actual amazing
relationships I am Jade warshaw your
co-host joined by Dr John deloney to my
right we're taking your calls for the
next hour we'll talk about your life
your money your mental health you can
give us a call 8825 5225 and we will do
our best to answer your questions and
number one I'm always grateful that you
guys even trust us with your life like
you guys call in you're willing to share
your numbers you're willing to share
your deepest darkest secrets we
definitely do not take that lightly so
thank you so so much and um another
thing that we don't take lightly thank
you for watching thank you for listening
uh one of the things that you guys do
that's so incredible that we're so
grateful for uh is you share the show
and my I'm like can you just keep doing
that if you like the show click the
little like button if this is done
something for you subscribe or if you
know someone that would benefit from the
things that we're talking about out in
here every day go ahead and you know
share the episode with them slide them
the little paper airplane so they can
see it uh send them a you know link text
it to them that does so so much um not
only for us it does a lot for us because
it's great for the algorithm but it does
a lot for people because we exist here
to help you guys and help people and
that's our great privilege and honor so
thank you for doing that John I'm ready
to go to these phone lines cuz we got
Allison in Toledo Ohio Allison what's
going on
girl hi thank you for taking my call
we're doing good how are you I'm good um
so my question is I have a daughter
that's going to be going to college next
fall um the problem is she has been
struggling with an eating disorder for
five years um we've been through like
numerous therapists dietitians
residential stays uh she's stable but
nowhere near recovery um I don't want
her to go to college but her therapist
thinks I need to just kind of her go and
I can't make her recover she doesn't
want that want to do that herself and I
guess I'm just scared because I'm afraid
she's gonna go and then
she's she's sorry yeah um she's gonna go
and then she's just going to wither away
and I know I have a year away but I'm
just like terrified and I just don't
know how to deal with this no thank you
for sharing that
um o over the last two two decades I've
sat with a number of moms in your very
situation okay so you're not you're not
alone in that it's hard um and let's I I
always like to enter into these
conversations um especially in this kind
of format in a radio show um with as
much truth as possible is that cool yeah
okay you and I both know that disordered
eating is one of the if not the most
lethal Mental Health Challenge right
right it's not something to mess around
with and
we also know that when our kids are
hurting we will do anything and
sometimes what we do ends up but we
build
fences and in a weird way that can make
challenges for the growth and safety and
development and healing for some of
these challenges right until it becomes
this weird recursive I don't want to be
a part of the problem but my therapist
the therapist is saying I need to stop
doing this but I feel like I have to do
this and so here's what I would do um
okay is is there a risk of sending her
away 100% absolutely no question about
that anyone who tells you there's not
they're lying to you okay okay
and I have been a part of multiple teams
at multiple universities from a giant R1
research institution with 35 or 40,000
students at it to a small faith-based
community and the other universities in
between that with a parent and with a
student and with the right care team
what made up of of a nutritionist and
made up of uh Mental Health Providers on
campus and sometimes medical providers
on campus there ends up being an amazing
team and then you throw in residence
hall directors and the ability to make
friends and get community okay there is
an opportunity it sounds to me like you
a have concerns about her health and
well-being which are all true and you
have a licensed mental health
professional saying in her professional
opinion this is the next best right move
that's number one number two it ALS also
sounds like you need to do some
work dealing with the opening of your
hands and letting your daughter move to
the next stage of her life which is
scary to do is that fair yeah yeah and I
actually have been seeing a therapist
past month and I mean she says that too
she does good so um it's hard when when
a mental health professional tells me a
parent uh maybe you've got some stuff
you need to work on and I'm like no it's
they're the ones with and so follow
follow the wisdom of the of the
Professionals in front of you okay and
I'm going to tell you to balance that
with go with your gut moms especially
but moms and dads are pretty intuitive
but if I'm sitting my kid and I'm in
your situation okay I have a
seven-year-old little girl and I
wouldn't wish it on her as you wouldn't
wish it on anybody but let's say I find
myself in the same situation what I
would do is sit down with the college
that my daughter's going to go to and we
would sit down with the there's going to
be a care team a student support and
emergency team there's going to be some
group of people that have a 360 degree
view of your daughter academically
residence hall experience mental health
provider Etc and we're going to create a
plan and everybody's going to be a part
of that plan and a part of that plan
will be the school will call you if they
get really concerned about the health
and safety of your
daughter okay okay so do you think a
smaller school would be a better choice
then um I think there's going to be I I
I say that because they may not have the
resources of a larger school so I don't
I don't know that I think it's going to
be very specific to your individual
situation and where your daughter feels
like she is going to be safe and where
she's going to have a good experience um
and here's the deal I'm not special guys
like me men and women like me all across
the country chair these teams I ched one
of these teams at several different
places okay so if you can just imagine a
knucklehead like me sitting down saying
okay do we have the right therapist the
Right medical provider we've got the
right people here and then the work on
the other end is let the professionals
do their job and
Mom you do the work on opening your
hands up and letting your daughter who's
now an adult slowly transition into
adulthood okay which stinks I know did
you want me just to say no keep her home
don't ever let her grow up would that
have been so much easier no no I just
I've been trying to be so strong we're
going to college visits and I'm being
like really excited for her but like
inside I'm a nervous breath
you can be
both okay and hey I think it's fair to
tell your daughter I love you to the
moon and back and there's nothing in the
world other than maybe your dad that I
love more than you and so I'm your mom
it's going to be hard on me we divorced
oh you're divor okay so no so in many
ways she might have been your identity
for a long time
right yeah has she been your purpose and
reason for being yeah she's been
propping you up for a long time and it's
going to you're going to have to tell
her I'm going to have to work to let you
go and so it's going to be hard hard for
me your mom and it's not her job to make
you feel better that's not her job ever
ever ever that's your job to do that
kind of work
right right and so I would be honest
with her be honest with her she's smart
she's going to college she's smart and
she loves her mom and also um trusted
Professionals in in in her world there's
going to be a whole team of them if you
pick the right school I'm proud of you
for going to counseling on your own too
this a hard hard hard season you're
going through this is the ramsy show
[Music]
if you have questions with your money
questions about your budget questions
about college choice questions about
mental health choices you're feeling
anxious about money anxious about
student loans coming back if the
national debts got you feel in some type
of way if the debates have you feel in
some type of way man give us a call we
want to talk about all of that you'd be
surprised at how all of these things
filter into our choices that we make
with our life and our money and if we're
not aware of that on Down the Line we'll
look up and be like oh my gosh I've
created a mess so if any of those things
are on your mind give us a call the
number Isle 8825 5225 will help sort it
out with you it would be our great
pleasure let's go to Matt in Mesa
Arizona what's going on
Matt hi thanks for taking my call you
bet hey um exactly what you were saying
there um some of those things you know
inflation and come on it's real right
you're feeling it factor in yeah they
factor in but my questions um
specifically with Bitcoin and I I'll get
to it but where my wife and I are at
is um through baby step four so we're
completing um and contributing 15% to
our retirement account and then the next
steps are obviously the 529 or college
savings and paying off the house right
uh we're not there salary-wise to start
contributing to five and six yet uh
maybe in a couple years with a raise
we'll start doing that but we have about
a Bitcoin in
uh just saved up so if you cash it out
after taxes it'll probably be worth 20K
would you by that's my question for you
um relating to bitcoin what would you do
with that Bitcoin in the situation that
um that I'm in are you guys how long
have you how long have you had
it since 2015 has it been so
fun yeah it's been a roller coaster it
seems like it's been like more of like a
backyard
slide yeah
I yeah so like just directly from top to
bottom I'm just glad you're ready get
out of it dude I would sell it before
the day was over most definitely and um
you know you're you're contributing the
15% to retirement like you should be um
I'm not mad at you guys using that and
kind of putting a a chunk into the 529
if you wanted to do that because that is
important how many kids do you have we
have a four-year-old and entally you
know another one next year which might
be some of that savings if if we cash it
out save some of that for another kid
yeah when it comes to the 529
uh we don't have as many hard and fast
rules on the amount that you have to
contribute and how often you should
contribute and all those things because
the fact of the matter is everybody's
situation with their kids when it comes
to their education is going to be
different and you're at the stage where
you really can't predict it at all like
you know you don't know if they're going
to grow up to want to do ivy league or
if they're going to do the trades or if
they're a musician and they just want to
rock out you like you don't know what
that's going to be and so as a parent
it's really up to you to choose the best
option I don't know that I would start
with 20 ,000 that just feels like a lot
and once you're in it you're kind of
locked in now not obviously down the
line that money can re can you know
convert into retirement money and it can
go to different siblings so that's a
conversation between you and your wife I
do want you to be contributing something
into that 529 but also know that four
five and six um if possible should be
done simultaneously so I'm not mad at
the idea of taking some of that money
and putting it into the 529 to get it
rolling and then taking the rest of it
and throwing it towards a mortgage how
much do you owe on your
mortgage um 235 235 you know that's up
to you there's not a wrong answer on
this if it were me if I woke up in your
shoes if I woke up in your shoes I might
reverse engineer it a little differently
I'd probably throw like a th000 into the
529 and be like okay every year I'm
going to put x amount of dollars in and
I'd probably put the bigger chunk toward
the mortgage that's what I would do I
mean maybe even have a contest with your
wife and see if y'all could get down to
where it was
199,999 bucks before Christmas or
something like that they just feel good
right yeah oh yeah when you get to when
you get below the z00 oh you start
making those moves and so I I that's
that's probably what I would do how what
what did you buy into Bitcoin what was
your initial Buy in uh I bought half for
300 bucks okay and then a whole one for
1,500 bucks I I already got my money
back okay you're good yeah I I love that
you're just willing to sell it I think
that's the right move as far as what
percentages to put where I don't think
there's a wrong answer but I think I
don't think there's a wrong answer in my
mind what feels a little bit more wise I
hate to use the word wise what feels
like there's less um unknown let me put
it like that is you know you've got to
pay your house off um you know you
that's that's a given you know you want
to have some money set aside for some
further education your child you don't
know what that's going going to be yet
so it's not like we have to have 150,000
set aside for school you don't know that
you know so there is some thought with
that you might say hey we're going to
put 20,000 in we're going to set it and
forget it and let it grow and what it is
it is so those it actually Sparks um
Matt some bigger conversations about
education and you and your wife sitting
down and going okay what's our goal here
uh 529 is great yeah we want to add to
it but what are we saying we're going to
contribute are we saying we're going to
match them dollar for dooll regardless
of how they further their education is
our plan that we're going to fund
whatever that thing is 100% is our plan
is you know so I think that's honestly
the first conversation and then whatever
you guys come away from that
conversation will uh lead you down if
you're going to put most of it towards a
mortgage or put most of it towards a 529
and I'll say this too I spent most of my
career in higher ed and I've got a
13-year-old who's just a few years out
and I've got a
seven-year-old I
am I have not a a single doubt in my
mind that what I know to be college and
the university experience right now will
be different for my
seven-year-old yeah so that's where
we're at we're conflicted on um what to
do in that situation so I I think you're
right it makes more sense to with any
extra cash pay down the house and even
having grandparents that would more than
likely step in to help for some of that
college for a grand kid um I wouldn't
count on it yeah not planning on that
but um like you said not necessarily
wiser but maybe the more for sure thing
is to pay down the mortgage so and again
start with that conversation with your
wife like set the expectations so you
know what the goal is because it it's
you know sometimes with this stuff we
just start throwing darts and it's like
hey I know I'm supposed to do something
like that and I know I'm supposed to do
something like that and it's like yeah
throw $1,000 in there throw $1 in there
but what really motivates us and what
really makes us feel awesome about what
we're doing is when we know exactly what
we're aiming towards and why then as you
get closer it's like that's freaking
awesome like we're really doing
something so that's what I'd say Matt
feel good about it thank you yeah I
think the the mindset has changed after
having a kid and just kind of settling
down a little bit where we want to have
more peace with our finances being you
know kind of no kids or uh before that
single and and I've never needed the
Bitcoin but I think that's it's it's
hard to have the mindset of well so
volatile it could go up 200,000 and it
could also go down and so I don't really
want to sell it which is kind of why I'm
calling in yeah but uh having peace with
with finances is probably more important
for us so I'll have that confirmation
conversation with my wife and and uh go
from there I think I think it's worth it
look you guys are out of debt number one
so it's not like I'm like sell this to
get out of debt um what's your net worth
by the way like what do you what else do
you have invested I'm just
curious uh good question um Beanie
Babies we always say like things like
this Bitcoin and and single stocks and
um little things like that that you just
are dabbling around in you don't want
that to be more than 5% of your big
picture and you certainly don't want to
be putting money into those things
currently until after baby step 7 until
after you're you know doing all the
doing all the important things right
then it's like when you have money to
play if you have money to play um you
might do stuff like that but the way it
sounded did um you I feel like when you
first called in you said hey we've got
the money to do baby step 4 but we don't
necessarily have it to do five and six
and so I think that right there was the
the dial that you turned that's like
okay then it's it's time to sell this
off if you were like hey we're just
rolling in the dough should I just go
ahead and sell this to I'd probably be
like H who cares but because it does
matter to you and it matters in your
world I definitely would sell it I think
you're making the right choice I love
these conversations John yeah and I I
never want people to forget if you don't
have a mortgage you can go a long way to
help cash flowing part of college too
when it comes around right oh yeah I
mean that's all that money freed up just
freed up money the mortgage is the
biggest piece of people's month-to-month
income and it's one thing when you go
from renting to ownership and it's a
whole other thing when you go from
ownership to no payments like I
literally own this free and clear you
can help cash flow a community college
with no problem oh that's what I'm
talking about this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
oh
what's going on people it is the ramsy
show I am Jade warshaw your host I got
John delone on the ones and twos to the
next to the next side of me remember
that when they used to say that I do I
do on the ones and twos I don't even SCH
I don't even know what that means I
guess it just means that you're uh I
thought it was the turntables yeah the
ones and twos though okay clearly I've
never worked a turntable umbles at a
microphone where it's at that's what I'm
talking about all right yes I got that
John I got that okay I know about Beck I
know what's going on here we're going to
go to Mela in Honolulu Hawaii Michaela
what's going
on hi yeah so I'm just trying to see if
I can figure out a plan to help me and
my family get out of um like living
paycheck to paycheck yes ma'am you're
living in one of the most expensive
places on the planet is it rough yes it
yeah it's rough um but there's no no
room to leave like I'm not leaving this
is my home so I just have to figure out
what to do next um can you give us a
little bit of a can you give us a a big
picture of what's going on can you tell
us what the debt is can you tell us what
the income is what help you out yeah so
my husband has about $220,000 in student
loan debt um I'm at home with two kids
so I can't really work um how old are
the kids and then he um five months old
and two and a half
okay yeah and then um he makes about
like 50,000 okay um he just finished his
degree um so like he's looking for more
jobs and he got offered a management
position at his job so that he doesn't
leave so there's potentially more money
coming in um but I mean it's not going
to be significant enough to really make
a dent if you know what I mean at first
yeah I mean what are we talking he goes
from 50 to 55 or he
goes right yeah okay that's right and so
just the 20,000 in student loans is
there anything
else no okay um 20,000 in student loans
feels like a lot when you're making
50,000 um 20,000 in student loans feels
a lot better when you're making 70,000
880,000 right right so what we need to
do is we need to open that Gap a little
bit because right now it's like man this
is almost half of my income and in the
United States you know the median income
is somewhere around 67,000 and I really
really really want to get you as close
to that as possible so you're staying
home with the kids I got to believe
there's something in this internet age I
believe I know Michaela there's
something that you can also be doing to
bring in some money right obviously
you're staying home with the kids cuz
you're like hey too expensive to put him
in child care right did I guess that
right right yeah I mean it's also just I
can't let somebody else watch my kids
too you know wait a minute hold on hold
on hold on you told me you can't move
you told me you can't let somebody watch
your kids you told me you can't work and
then you're calling us I've started a no
I've started a business so I'm trying to
work something that I can bring my kids
with to sell at uh our markets and stuff
here yes that's good can I got to cut
you off that's good but we need money to
day yeah you're you're drowning with
your
ideas with the way things like you're
you're you're non-negotiables are
burying you
guys you don't have enough
money right and so you're going to have
to you and your husband going have to
give like he wants to have this
management job cool I need you to go to
McDonald's and work the night shift
because I'm sure not working so you're
going to have to work two jobs or three
jobs or I'm gonna start seeing keeping
three of my neighbors kids over at our
house
but when when you go into a problem as
desperate as you're in we can't make the
bills and those little kids are
absorbing your husband's tension and
your tension and your
frustration and you go in with a whole
bunch of can't do that can't do that
can't do that can't do that that's a
tough way to solve a problem well you're
cutting you're cutting the legs out from
under you and it's not just you Michaela
we've been having this conversation all
afternoon with different callers
everything doesn't get the yes like
everything doesn't get to stay you do
have to to go through and go hey yeah
everybody look not everybody but most
parents have the ideal scenario for
their kids and that's what they want I
would love you I wish I could bring my
kids to work and I could see them all
day every day but I can't do that and do
this job uh so there's there's a give
and take there um when Sam and I my
husband and I were getting out of debt I
wanted to be able to do what everybody
else does which is you know you come
home after a long hard day you know you
you order a pizza on a Friday you watch
Netflix I didn't get to do that because
we had to pay off our debt and so
there's part of this that you just go
okay I have to make changes and they
will be painful and I want people to
hear that it doesn't feel good when
you're paying off your debt it sucks it
hurts you sacrifice you strain and you
push yourself to limits that you're like
man I don't feel like the guy next to me
has to push himself to the type of
limits that I'm pushing myself to but at
the end of the day you turn into a
different person and that is that is the
prize Michaela that's at the end of this
you turn yourself into a different
person number one that person's debt
free right but number two no one can
hold a candle to and no one can tell you
anything other than man like you're
confident like you can do what you say
you're going to do you can do hard
things you know how to prioritize you
know how to spend your time wisely that
builds something in you Michaela that is
going to be so Priceless and so
important throughout other because there
will be other storms in life
and this is going to create that well in
you that you're going to be able to dig
from and pull from and go hey remember
when we did XYZ remember when we doubled
our income and remember when we just
fought like dogs to get our income up
remember when we sacrificed everything
and we paid off that debt no one can
take that from you and so when you guys
sit down and you say okay what are we
going to sacrifice what are we going to
do are we going to do something with the
kids what does that look like am I going
to get EX am I going to put this dream
am I going to defer this dream of
whatever the business you have for just
a minute so I can make some money today
it is going to be so so worth it because
when you get to the point and you will
get to this point Michaela when you can
keep the kids home and when you can do
some of the things that you want to do
it's going to be that much more worth it
because you worked and sacrificed and
scrapped to get it how much H what's
minimum wage on in h Honolulu right now
$12 I think 11 actually 11 what
um there I mean we could drive I work at
a restaurant up in until I had my child
um here's here's what I'm wondering what
does October 1st through March 1st what
a six
months what a six months of a family
member a friend someone from your church
or even a local daycare center watching
your kids six months of you grinding it
and hating every day of
it but you grind it and then after at
March 1st you don't owe anybody any
money
right and then you are able to sit with
your kids and be fully present without
that Dragon hanging over your
shoulder and then by that time your
husband's moved from his management
position where it was just a little bit
of a raise to another position on the
island somewhere MH and what you're
talking about is six months and it feels
like a hundred years when you're holding
a five-month old but when I'm I have a
13-year-old now and I made some
sacrifices when he was young that allow
me and him to do some incredible things
that never would have happened when me
and my wife sat down and she said Are
you seriously going back to school and I
said I think I have to and I don't know
why but I think I have to no idea that
there was such thing called a podcast
and YouTube didn't exist right at least
any in any way that I knew about it and
so there's something about saying I'm
just going to suck it up for a season
for right now so that I can do these
other things when you get that money
coming in it's going to change your life
when you get that debt off your shoulder
changes your life you you find you find
a way to make $20,000 you know you can
live off 50 so you're out of debt in a
year if you can make this work and hey
before you get off the line we're going
to give you every dollar that is the
budgeting app that we created here at
Ramsey Solutions it's the only budgeting
app that I use back in 2015 when my
husband and I were in the thick of it
Ramsey was like here you go we made
every dollar and we made it to make this
easier for you and I've never looked
back we use that thing it's so helpful
it helps you plot your goals it helps
you see where you're at and by the way
Michaela I'm going to be doing webinar
um on October 10th uh it's at 11:30
Central Time where I'm going to really
walk through paycheck to paycheck living
how to break that cycle like
specifically the things that you're
talking about so I really want you to
tune into that webinar um please please
please make it a priority and be there
it's going to help you it's an hour long
it's a lunch break uh and anybody else
listening it's open to the public I
would love for you guys to sign up for
my webinar again 1010 we're going to be
going through the every dooll app making
sure you guys really have a handle on
how to use this thing how it's truly
going to help you break that paycheck to
paycheck cycle it's so important I'll
see you
[Music]
there
you are listening to the Ramsay show I
am Jade he is John we are taking calls
about your life and your money the
scripture and quote of the day it says
Ecclesiastes Ecclesiastes 49-10 he says
two are better than one because they
have a good return for their labor if
either of them falls down one can help
the other up but pity anyone who falls
and has no one to help them that's a
word right there Then Linda Grayson said
this there's nothing better than a
friend unless it's a friend with
chocolate look I ain't mad at that I
could use a little chocolate right now
John if you're my friend hey man you'll
find some I would love some chocolate
right now we don't have any um you know
I'm looking at the scripture
Ecclesiastes it says but pity the one
who falls and has no one to help them
and it's kind of funny you and I were
talking during the break John we get
calls all the time and I mean that's
what you call in right and you're hoping
that we can shed a little light on your
situation you're hoping that we can say
a couple of things that's going to put
you on the right track and and and
sometimes John folks call in and they've
already got a laundry list
prepared of a what they're not going to
do and be why it won't work right and
three what they can't do and what they
can't do and here's the thing and I said
this to John during the bre I'm just
being candid if you call in and you say
oh you know here's the thing I can't I
can't earn more um I can't move I can't
uh sacrifice this or that or that what
would happen if I just went oh oh okay
cool well sucks to be you then what if I
just you would not be okay with that you
would go well what kind of show is you
guys are supposed to give me advice you
guys are supposed to help me move
forward but here's the deal it only
works if you believe it works if we give
you a laundry list of things hey you
could try this you could do this uh
here's what worked for me here's what
worked for John and we're giving you
real life experience it's not a theory
we didn't just pull something out of our
butt and go hey try this you know it
might work for you we're telling you
time tested uh techniques when it comes
to money when it comes to life things
that not only worked for people out
there that you might not know or have
ever heard of but we're we're people
right here in this studio who are
telling you hey uh look we sacrificed we
slept on an air mattress John pulled
himself in and out of school he made
sacrifices to make it work for his
family we're telling you that and you
can either take it or you can leave it
right you lead a horse to water but you
can't make them drink but here's the
thing you came here for a drink and
we're trying to give you that and um the
belief thing it works either way right
whether you believe something works
or you believe it doesn't like that's
your choice so the things that we have
for you the resources that we have for
you you can make it true for you or you
can make it false for you you can say
hey like I believe this or I don't and
there's a big part of that like you've
got to you've got to connect to that and
you've got to stop saying I'm the
exception to the rule well and there
used to be a cultural ethos of we can do
anything yes we can go to the Moon we
can we can go liberate Europe we can go
fight this war we can do these things
and now our cultural ethos is y'all
can't you can't it's too hard too hard
someone's got to come get you you you
guys have too much pain you just you
can't and and Jade I too much standing
in your way I hear I'm frustrated by
that ethos of you can't because i' I've
just had the privilege for 20 something
years sitting with people who have
scratched and clawed and figured it out
and it's amazing to watch
and I'm frustrated by those who
say I'm not going to do that I can't do
that I can't I can't drive a Corolla yes
you can yes you can I can't I can't just
go go to work yes you can I just can't
drive in the morning before work and
then deliver pizzas at night I yes you
can there's always something you can do
to better your situation always I don't
care if it's just an inch forward you
keep compiling those inches and before
you know it you will have moved deps and
Bounds and miles further you can and
even if you can't move you can you can
reach out and say will you help me
absolutely will you help me will you
help me and there will be an army of
people there it's just this but you have
to receive the help John right I know
yeah it's it's a culture of
disempowerment that is so heartbreaking
to me um we have that last caller and I
just want to tell her I know you have
this vision for your life and that's
awesome and I actually think you can get
there but you're gonna have to stop
saying well I can't do that and I can't
do that and I can't do that yeah because
you're en canting yourself into a
miserable miserable Place yeah and and
the thing is we can all we can all look
at our lives and find reasons why it
won't work right like I could look at
myself I could be like well I I I went
to high school in a small town um I'm
black I'm a female it's harder for women
to get ahead um you know we've got this
debt uh we're just musicians musicians
you know it's Feast of fil and you know
you're starving artist you can make all
of these assumptions about yourself and
cause them to be true it's almost like
uh it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
like you're in a moment and the moment
sucks like let's be honest like
sometimes you can be in a moment and it
does feel like the walls are closing in
on you but the more you rehearse that in
your brain and continue to say it's true
and have no vision for the future I say
it all the time words matter Berne Brown
says whatever you go looking for you're
sure to find yes yeah she says that I
say it too and I know it came from
somebody but it's but it's a beautiful
thing like if I go looking for
opportunity yes we're talking on on the
plane today on the way on the way back
from New York when you said you and Sam
sat down and said if this is going to
actually work we got to start business
we have to yes we got to figure it out
we're going to start a business then and
it's like okay what do we know how to do
we're musicians so let's figure this out
and but it's a matter of hey Sheila when
we're doing it I'm going to have to
start adjuncting classes and I'm going
to have to become a professor on top of
my Dena students roles and I'm also
going to take this because we got to get
out of this mess and she's like I'm
going to lose you and I was like you're
going to lose me either way at least
this is our path of loss right yes and
you grind and you grind and you grind
and you grind then the Sun comes out it
does and but what you said John is
really important I don't think people
take enough time to look forward and
dream people don't take enough time to
go they're in the moment and they see
where they're at right now and it's like
H this is just this is me this is my
life this is how it is and I'm like no
let's take a moment and let's zoom out
for a moment in 10 years and 15 years
where would you like to be taking that
time
some taking time to just stare out of a
window and think you know what would it
be like if what would happen if I had
that conversation with my spouse what
would happen if we paid off both of our
vehicles like what would that feel like
taking the time and I challenge anybody
today take some time and dream think
about how your life could be better
write down a couple of ways write and
then write down what must be true
because let me tell you something uh
John with Sam and I you know for anybody
listening for the first time real quick
4 $460,000 of debt coming in into our
marriage from student loans and cars and
everything else and um I knew I wanted
not early on did I know I wanted a
family but a little further in I'm like
man I want a family this is never going
to happen you know like I want to be I
had this dream of like I want to be the
type of mom who can you know go to the
field trips and be there to pick their
kid up and you know I just had this very
clear vision and I was so so so so
unbelievably far from that and it broke
my heart and I remember saying to my
husband I'm like I can't like I can't
bring kids into this like we've got to
clean up this mess we will be bringing
them into such a mess and there was
other things going on as well too and I
remember sitting down and just being
like okay what's got to be true for
anything that we want in life to happen
because this right here it ain't it and
this is not working and we're so worth
more than this and that's a hard
conversation but once you have it it's
like okay there's the North Star let's
start reversing reverse engineering this
this thing backwards what's got to
happen first and then honestly enough
people don't sit down with pen and paper
and literally write down what has to
happen A1
first
and if if you don't have a map it's
really hard to what's that what's that
old saying if you don't have a m um you
don't know where you're going You're
sure to you're sure to get there right
you just Meander around if a if you aim
at nothing you hit it every time that's
right so yeah I if you hear us say
anything folks who are still listening
to this you can you can when you think
you can and it's it's 2 2: a.m. and
you're exhausted and you just looked at
your credit card
balance and you're in bed with somebody
that said I do and yall are so far apart
from each other and your kids don't want
to be around you and you think I'm out
you can and it's a little bitty step and
sometimes it's reaching out and saying I
don't know what to do next will you help
me please go make that call make that
that Stu and then go Get It Go Get It Go
do it look we're normal people all of us
are out here scratching and clawing if
John can do it if I can do it I know it
sounds cliche but you can surely do it
you can tell me you won't do it but do
not ever tell me you can't you can do
this all things are possible this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show hey what's up guys it's Jade look
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the ramsy baby steps
go to ramsy solutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step for you based on
your specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
[Music]
started